done
はぁんっ
はぁんっん
[音楽]
ん
me
皆さんは身近に
自分とは性格が違うな感じる人間がいますか
私はいます
私の音周助です
私たち夫婦は二人とも元気でおしゃべりなのでよく同じタイプの人間に思われがちなん
ですが
実は真逆の人間です
夫はポジティブで基本的にやりたいことは
ぜーったいなんとかなるからまず行動に沿って言うタイプデー
死ぬこと以外かすり傷
生きてるだけで丸儲け
そんな成功者たちの言葉を体現したような人間で
自社に数年前
2事故で死にかけました
そのとき夫は脊髄相生位
車椅子での生活を余儀なくされましたが
その後も前向きに自分のやりたいことにどんどんチャレンジしています
一方で私は
とてもネガティブな人間です
私だって彼のようにやりたいことをやって後悔しない人生の方が素敵やなってそう思い
ます
だけどその一歩が踏み出せません
リスクばかり目がいって
かすり傷をすることさえこある
そう感じてしまいます
こんな真逆の性格ですから普段ケンカも本当に多いんです
これは数ヶ月前
夫からいきなり私に送られてきたチャット内容です
キーを経験したこともない音が
スキーでパラリンピック目指したいからフランスに収用にかしてくれ
そんな内容でした
私はいやまた脊髄損傷なる世斗兄がのリスクを考えて猛反対するんです
そうすると夫は言い返してきで私もいい関して
最終的に良いアイスになるんですよね
もういつもこんな感じ喧嘩ばっかしてるので極力共同作業を避けてきた私たちなんです
が
それでも一緒にチャレンジしていることが一つだけあります
それがこの竜王9プロジェクトです
このプロジェクトは2年前
交通事故で音が歩けなくなったことをきっかけに
夫婦でクラウドファンディングで立ち上げたプロジェクトです
現在の日本の病院では
一度脊髄損傷で完全麻痺と診断されると
一般的には車いすを前提にしたリハビリになります
それでも諦めきれなかった私たちは歩くための再生料とか
リハビリの情報を集めて
それを同じ思いを持つできるだけ多くの人に届けるために
このプロジェクトを立ち上げました
結果このプロジェクトでは525名の支援をいただいて
540万円を資金として集め
web サイトを作ったり
今年4月には200人規模のイベントを主催するなどして情報発信の活動を続けてき
ました
このプロジェクトをきっかけにヤフーニュースに掲載いただいたり
オーストラリアにあるグリフィス大学にある再生医療の研究所にご招待いただいたり
研究の一環として筑波大学附属病院の春を利用した治療の機会をいただきました
私はこの調整を通じて
調整をすればチャンスを掴むことができるんやってそう
体感しました
20年間サッカーを続け命の次に大切な足
そう言っていた音にとってこの事故は本当に辛い出来事でしたが
夫は命を助けてくれたを者様周りのサポートに感謝しながら
常に前向きにリハビリに取り組みました
そして
無理と言われても納得がいくまでリハビリを続けたい
そういって彼は最終的にオーストラリアでのリハビリを決めました
一方で私はホットの事故後
とてもネガティブな考えが頭の中を駆け巡っていました
オーストラリアでのリハビリを決めた時も
先にありました
だけど
このオーストラリア異教提案したのは実は夫ではなくて私だったんです
実はこのプロジェクトは私たち夫婦の真逆の性格が功を奏したと言っても過言ではあり
ません
夫は前に進む力はあるんですがリスクヘッジが苦手です
私はリスクヘッジのためにポコッとにリサーチしまくります
歩くための情報を毎日ネットで検索しまくって病院やてに手紙を書いたり介護員の友人
にいやヒアリングするなどして
海外のリハビリ情報にたどり着きました
これまでもネガティブやったからこそ人生の選択肢を広げることができました
大学は4年間アメリカに留学
今年は友人と会社も立ち上げました
そうネガティブであってもチャレンジすることができるんです
ネガティブな私が挑戦をするとき
いつも大切にしていることそれが今回お話する
おまけをもらいに行くという発想です
さてここからが問題です
皆さんはこんな経験ありませんか
小さい時自分の好きなキャラクターのシールやカードおもちゃなど
おまけのついたお菓子をついつい買ってしまったという経験
顔気がなかった雑種とか漫画を一緒に付いてる付録が魅力的で
もう買ってしまった予定経験それ以外にも
今なら入会金無料とか一つ買うともう一つおまけへとか
こんなあのおまけが決め手になって何かを買った
決断したそんな経験ないでしょうか
いやーこのね店と変わらへんけどこんな a ことが付いてくるなお得やな
のようにおまけは一見ハードが高いと思われる商品のオーディオするモチベーションを
作り出したり
人の決定の後押しをしてますよね
何をするにもネガティブで一歩が踏み出せない私は
このおまけをたくさんもらえに行くことを常に意識しています
ではおまけ主な餌にいくってどういうことでしょうか
例えば挑戦して得た妹のやりたいことがあったとします
今回の夫が挑んだ海外のリハビリのケースやと歩けるようになるっていうのがこれです
よね
でももしこれで失敗したら
つまり夫が海外のリハビリで歩けなかったとしなぁ
この時得られる価値はゼロになる
そう2考えますよね
時間やお金かけたのに得られるもが0
自分の挑戦って無駄になってしまうかもしれん
すると足がすくんで一歩が踏み出せなくなります
そこで私はこの歩けるというせいか意外に得られるもの
この調整でどうんなオマケがもらえるかっていうのを具体的に想像してるんです
例えば海外でリハビリすることで海外に友達ができる
海外にリハビリとか再生医療の情報でとワークができる
海外と日本のリハビリとかいい用の違いを知ることができる
夫の英語力アップなどこれらこの挑戦で得られるおまけを次々創造していくことで何か
この挑戦の価値が大きくなったら気がしませんか
一つの目標を目指してこんなにいいことあるんやったらちょっとやってみてもいいか
もってそんな気持ちになりませんか
何私は先ほど4年間大学アメリカに留学したと言いましたが
留学を決断した時もこのおまけの端数を使いました
将来は世界を駆け巡るキャリア甘いになりたい
アメリカンドリームや
そんな生意気な夢を小学生のどっか語ってた私は
ウッドアメリカ留学を夢見てました
いろいろ不安はありましたが得意のリサーチで年に比べて学費も比較的安くて
し雨も安心できてなおかつ留学生のスカラシップ制度が整っていた
アラバマにある大学を夢の留学先として選びました
私が入った場所はとても小さいとお待ちだったんですけども
それでも英語を学びたいアメリカで勉強したいという私の夢をかなえるには十分な環境
でした
それでも
いや親にこんなにお金かけてもらったのに失敗したらどうしよう
卒業でき方どうしよう
そんなプレッシャーに押しつぶされそうになったとき私はふと
この挑戦で自分が得られるものを考えてみようってそう思いました
いやーあらばに行った日本人ってめちゃ珍しい今後グローバルで働く自分の特徴になる
かもしれないとか
アラームあらが待ってナムなんでアメリカ南部の
月岡おい歴史や文化を勉強できるぞとか
小さいマジだからこそいろんな人と仲良くなって何かできそうとか
そうやって行く前からアラバマについて調べて自分の得られるおまけをどんどん想像し
ていくとなんか自分の調整がお得な掲載しました
そしてとんでもなく
隠したことを覚えています
私が音に海外のリハビリを提案したとき実はこんな風に考えてました
いっぱいするのは強いったけどどうせやるんやったら
おまけもらいにいこーっ
障害でできないことに目が行きがちらからこそ
夫にできることを増やしてあげたいっ
何かやろうとするとき
どうしても失うもんばっかりに滅入ってしまいます
そして不安が重なっていつしかやーない理由ばかりを考えてしまうようになります
でもそんな時いかに自分が挑戦しやすくなる環境を自分で作り出せるか
朝鮮からたくさんのおまけを見つけて来られることを
どんだけ楽しめるか
それがネガティブなりに挑戦してチャンスをつかむための私なりの考え方の工夫です
さて
今夫はオーストラリアでのリハビリを終えました
夫は歩けるようにはなりませんでした
だけど
毎日何時間もリハビリをして
足の膝下を自分で動かせるという奇跡的な回復を見せました
またたくさんの表を抱えて日本に帰ってきました
英語力もアップし
現地に一生の友達と呼べる存在が出来ました
砂浜の上を車いすで移動できるビーチマットに出会い
事故後初めて海に入りました
そしてオーストラリアに歩いてまたみんなに会いに来る
そんなあーたの夢が出来ました
世界には一緒に頑張っている仲間の存在がいる
それを知ることができた夫は世界中一人でどこへでも出かけて
先月私への宣言通り本当にフランスに行ってチェアスキーを始めました
夫はこれからツヤ好きでパラリンピックを目指して自身の経験を通じてシェアスキーの
楽しさを世界中の子どもたちに教えたいそうです
夫のリハビリに付き添ってオーストラリアに行ったことで私もまたたくさん
を設けをもらいました
美しいビーチが見られる最高の環境で夫婦でともに時間を過ごせただけでなく
日本にいなくてもできる仕事を見つけました
ゴールドコーストマラソンのハーフマラソンに人生初のハーフマラソンに挑戦しました
ヨガの聖地バイロンベイに入ってヨガ修行しました
そこでもまた世界中からの素敵な様が仲間たちの出会いがありました
ヨガの経験を生かしてトレーナーの指導のもと夫のリハビリを手伝えるようにもなり
ました
そしてまた私にも
現地に一生の友達ができました
夫の人口を通じてたくさんの人に出会い
その出会いの中から新しい居場所を見つけ
今もやりたいことを見つけては
一つの挑戦からたくさんのおまけをもらいに行くこと
それをモットーに
調整の場を広げています
石橋を叩きまくって前に進むネガティブもうしたのは私と
ブルドーザーのように前に答申するポジティブモンスター直人
お互いスタイルは違えど
前に進んでいることは確かです
そしてこんな真逆の性格の私たちも
共通していることが一つだけありますそれは
結局自分がやるって決めたら
たとえ失敗する可能性が高くても
その道は正しかったって言えるように全力投球していることです
何かやろうとする時自分の選択が最善の選択かどうかなんてその時は分かりません
というかやって終わるまで分からないもんだと思います
夫が事故で歩けなくなったとき
私たち夫婦はある約束をしました
それはこの事故のせいでではなくて
この事故があったからこそ今幸せなんやってそう言えるような人生にしようって言っ
そのために無理と言われても限界まで歩くことにチャレンジです予定
そう決めてからの私たちは本当にいい子でした
応援してくれる人の期待を裏切らないようにそして自分自身を裏切らないように
自分の選択や朝鮮に責任を持つ
それはポジティブもネガティブも関係ありません
大きなことができなくても
自分できることを地道によってそして最後にん
自分の挑戦にはこんなに価値があったってそう言えること
その学びこそが
本当に自分にとってのおまけ何やって思います
こんなに臆病で自信のない私が
なぜ今日ここに立つて決めたのか
こんなに行っちゃ水チャンスをいただいたのにうまく話せんかったらどうしようって
そんな恐怖が私を襲いました
だけど
今日うまく自分の思うようにここで話せなかったとしても私はあるおまけがあると思っ
て
強国に立っています
それは
ここに立って話すことは間違いなく私のトークスキル向上に役立ったということ
このトークの原稿を作るにあたって
事故からこれまでの活動という意味をあらためて整理できたこと
自分のネガティブは悪いもんじゃない
そう自分の良さをポジティブに受け止められたこと
9日以上に2 party とたった一人でもいいから
何か新しいことに挑戦してみようそうやって思ってもらえること
テックス頭に拘らなければ出会えなかった人がここにいるっていうこと
そして最後にし後からこれまで私たち夫婦をいろんなところで支えてくれた人たちに
ありがとうを伝えられることです
本当にありがとうございました
[拍手]